From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And I hold in my hands a children's book called Nobody's Family is Going to Change , published in the 1970s by the same writer who did Harriet the Spy , Louise Fitzhugh. It is, I have to say, an oddly menacing title, Nobody's Family is Going to Change. Various contributors to our show have joked that it's part of a series for kids, with The Little Princess Who Got Sick and Never Woke Up , Daddy Drinks Because You Cry , God Made the Pretty Girls Pretty Because He Loved Them More, and Sharing is for Sissies .
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我手里拿着一本20世纪70年代出版的儿童书，名叫《没人能改变家庭》，作者是写过《哈丽特间谍》的路易丝·菲茨休。不得不说，这是一个非常令人不安的书名，《没人能改变家庭》。我们节目的多位撰稿人曾开玩笑说，这可能是给孩子们看的一系列丛书之一，书名还包括《生病且永远没醒来的小公主》、《爸爸因为你哭而喝酒》、《上帝让美女更美因为他更爱她们》，以及《分享是懦夫的行为》。
But in fact, it's a serious and really good and rather brave little book, Nobody's Family is Going to Change . There's a family, as you might expect, the Sheridans, with a mean, disapproving dad; a mom who tries to smooth things over; a son who wants to dance in a show but is told he can't by his father; a daughter Emma, who is accused of daydreaming too much. She wishes that her family could be different.
但事实上，这本名为《没人能改变家庭》的书，其实是一本既严肃又出色且颇为勇敢的小书。正如你所料，书中讲述了一个家庭，谢里丹一家，有一个刻薄、挑剔的父亲；一个试图调解矛盾的母亲；一个想在演出中跳舞却被父亲禁止的儿子；还有一个总是被指责白日梦太多的女儿艾玛。她希望自己的家庭能有所不同。
Over the course of the book, Emma tries to get her dad to change, to listen to them, to be kind. She joins something called the Children's Army, which agitates for the notion that is a child's right to change his or her family. And then, finally towards the end of the book, sitting at dinner, as her father and brother rehash the same fight that they always have, Emma realizes that her parents will never change. Her dad will always be harsh, will never treat her or her brother like he cares about them, and that she can't change him and shouldn't try. And the best she can do is change herself.
在书的进程中，艾玛试图让父亲改变，让他倾听家人的心声，让他变得友善。她加入了一个叫“儿童军”的组织，该组织鼓吹一个理念，即孩子有权改变自己的家庭。最后，在书的结尾，晚饭时，当她的父亲和哥哥又在争吵那场他们一直重复的架时，艾玛意识到父母永远不会改变。她的父亲永远严厉，永远不会像关爱家人那样对待她和哥哥，她无法改变他，也不应该去尝试。她唯一能做的就是改变自己。
So she goes and tells her friends, who have trouble understanding it. There's a scene.
于是她去告诉朋友们，但朋友们很难理解。有这样一幕。
"What about my father?" asked Golden.
“那我父亲呢？”戈尔登问道。
"Your father," said Saunders, "is a lost cause. He thinks boys are great, and he's never going to think you're anything because you're a girl."
“你父亲，”桑德斯说，“无可救药了。他觉得男孩才了不起，因为你是女孩，他永远不会看重你。”
"Well," says Golden, "I can't change that."
“好吧，”戈尔登说，“我无法改变这一点。”
"No, but you could stop wanting him to change," said Saunders.
“不，但你可以停止期待他改变，”桑德斯说。
Emma felt like the top of her head would fly off. Saunders got it, the whole thing. "That's what I mean," said Emma loudly. "That's just what I'm talking about. We have to stop waiting around for them to love us."
艾玛感觉自己的头盖骨都要飞走了。桑德斯懂了，完全懂了。“这就是我的意思，”艾玛大声说。“我说的就是这个。我们必须停止等待他们来爱我们。”
Because it's the '70s, one of the kids suggested they form a consciousness-raising group.
因为那是70年代，其中一个孩子建议他们成立一个提高觉悟的小组。
The fact is, even those of us who are adults, who know better, who accept our parents and siblings as we hope that they accept us, even we hope, somehow, that maybe it'll change a little, this way or that. It's hard not to hope. And the question's on the table. Is nobody's family going to change? Today, three stories that explore whether that might be true.
事实是，即使是我们这些成年人，明明知道应该怎么做，明明接受了父母和兄弟姐妹并希望他们也接受我们，我们仍然会抱有一丝希望，希望他们能有所改变。不抱希望真的很难。问题摆在面前：难道真的没有家庭能改变吗？今天，有三个故事探讨这一命题是否成立。
Act One, So a Jew, a Christian, and a Recording Crew Walk Into This Bar. In that act, a woman travels to Alaska, thinking that maybe her brother might change a little, as he hopes that she'll change a little, too.
第一幕，“犹太人、基督徒和录音组走进酒吧”。在这一幕里，一位女性前往阿拉斯加，想着也许她的哥哥能改变一点点，正如他希望她也能改变一点点一样。
Act Two, Matching Outfits Not Included. The story of two sisters, now in their 70s, who have preserved the same relationship they had as girls, for better or worse.
第二幕，“不含配套服装”。这是关于一对70多岁的姐妹的故事，无论好坏，她们保持着和女孩时期一模一样的关系。
Act Three, The Artist Formerly Known as Dr. Sarkin. What happens when you want your dad to change, and he wants to change, but there is literally nothing that can be done to change him? Stay with us.
第三幕，“曾被称为萨金博士的艺术家”。当你想要父亲改变，他也想改变，但实际上却毫无办法改变他时，会发生什么？请继续收听。
Act One. Julia Pimsleur's brother, Marc, went through a dramatic change, years ago now. And I think it's not exaggerating to say that she wanted him to change back, at least a little, back to the way he was when they were young. And so she set out on a little mission to see him and talk and get his side of things. And experiment to see if anybody would change.
第一幕。朱莉娅·平斯勒的哥哥马克，几年前经历了一场剧烈的转变。我想说，她希望他能变回来，至少变回一点点，变回他们小时候的样子。于是她踏上了一趟小小的旅程，去见他、交谈并了解他的想法。这是一个关于看看是否有人能改变的实验。
Marc and I were very close when we were small. We traveled a lot, so we really only had each other for many months at a time. We went to Ghana and we went to Switzerland, we went to Germany, sometimes for many months at a time when my dad was teaching. So my earliest memories are just of  this little family unit-- my dad, my mother, my brother, and me.
马克和我小时候非常亲密。我们经常旅行，所以很多时候我们几个月的时间里只有彼此。我们去过加纳、瑞士、德国，有时因为父亲教书的缘故，我们会在那里待上好几个月。所以我最早的记忆就是这个小家庭单元——爸爸、妈妈、哥哥和我。
Julia and I were always together. She and I, we had each other. We'd play and talk and stuff. I don't even remember fighting at all until the year my dad died. Then we moved to New York.
朱莉娅和我总是待在一起。她和我，我们有彼此。我们玩耍、聊天之类的。在爸爸去世那年之前，我甚至完全不记得我们吵过架。然后我们搬到了纽约。
That year was when everything changed for all of us. We just became very isolated into our separate worlds at that point. My brother and I no longer shared a room from that point on. And I don't think we were much of a family unit ever again after that. Somehow, the three of us couldn't make it a family unit again. I would like to talk with Marc about my father, but it's too late now because he has decided that everything that came before he was born again doesn't really matter.
那一年，我们所有人的生活都改变了。从那时起，我们变得非常孤立，各自活在自己的世界里。从那以后，我和哥哥不再住同一个房间了。我觉得在那之后，我们再也没有成为一个真正的家庭单元了。某种程度上，我们三个人再也无法重组家庭。我本来想和马克谈谈关于父亲的事，但现在太晚了，因为他决定在他重生之前所发生的一切都不重要了。
I was at home and I was in one of my states where I was just totally depressed and confused. So I opened the Bible. And I don't remember what the scripture was. It was something like, why are you stressed out? Today is a day of joy.
当时我在家，处于一种极度沮丧和困惑的状态中。于是我翻开了圣经。我不记得具体的经文是什么了。大概是说，你为什么压力这么大？今天是快乐的一天。
I read that and all of a sudden, I realized God loved me, right there. And it just hit me like an atom bomb. I just felt it so powerfully. I was like, "God loves me." And it just went like, [BOMB SOUND] inside. And it just kept going on--
我读了那段话，突然之间，我意识到上帝爱我，就在那一刻。那种感觉就像原子弹一样击中了我。我感受得如此强烈。我心想：“上帝爱我。”那种感觉就像在内心——[炸弹声]——不断激荡。
I guess, starting chronologically, my brother went to UC Berkeley and dropped out and became a born-again Christian and moved to a small island in Alaska to join a separatist community.
我想，按时间顺序来说，我哥哥去了加州大学伯克利分校，后来退学成了重生基督徒，并搬到了阿拉斯加的一个小岛上，加入了一个分裂主义社区。
I mean, I was like, on fire, physically. I mean, in a good way. it was like this, just blinding light, the whole thing. There was no way I could dispute that something was happening. Something big was happening. And--
我是说，我当时在身体上就像着了火。我是说，以一种好的方式。就像某种耀眼的光芒，整件事都是。我无法反驳正在发生的事情。有什么大事正在发生。并且——
He called home and said that he had moved to a place called The Farm. And we asked where that was, and he said it was on a small island near Juneau and that he was living with 75 people in a self-sufficient farming community, and they considered themselves born-again Christians.
他打电话回家说他搬到了一个叫“农场”的地方。我们问那是在哪，他说在朱诺附近的一个小岛上，他和75个人住在一个自给自足的农耕社区里，他们认为自己是重生基督徒。
--I went outside and I was like, I felt like a newborn baby. And I looked up at the sky and it was just getting to be evening and I could see the stars and I was like, wow. It was like I was seeing everything for the first time. And--
——我走到外面，感觉自己像个新生儿。我抬头看着天空，天色渐晚，我能看见星星，我心想，哇。感觉就像第一次看到万物一样。并且——
At first, when he joined The Farm, it almost made us closer because he had been out of the house for several years. I spent my last years of high school with him away. So we didn't talk then and he was traveling a lot. And then he was at Berkeley and I didn't hear from him much. And then, when he came home one year, it was when he had started to have these religious experiences and he confided in me. He didn't tell my mother because he knew she would be very freaked out, and he told me.
起初，当他加入“农场”时，这反而让我们更亲近了，因为他已经离家好几年了。我高中最后几年他都不在。所以那时我们不怎么说话，他到处旅行。后来他在伯克利，我也不太听得到他的消息。后来，有一年他回家，那是他开始有这些宗教体验的时候，他向我倾诉。他没告诉妈妈，因为他知道她会吓坏，他只告诉了我。
And so I remember, initially, feeling really close to him again and very special and happy that he had chose to confide in me. And I kept his secret and we talked about it-- long talks about it, and I think he was very relieved that I didn't seem terrified at what he was telling me. But then, over the next few years, as he got more and more involved with The Farm, I felt like he was part of their world and not part of our world. And his language changed and he was talking about Jesus all the time in terms that didn't make any sense to us.
所以我记得起初，再次感到和他很亲近，感到很特别，很高兴他选择向我倾诉。我保守了他的秘密，我们谈论过它——关于这件事的漫长交谈，我想他很庆幸我对他所说的话并没有感到恐惧。但后来几年，随着他越来越多地参与“农场”的事务，我觉得他成了他们世界的一部分，而不是我们世界的一部分。他的语言变了，他一直在谈论耶稣，谈论的内容我们根本无法理解。
And then about five years ago, he came to visit me in France where I was living with my girlfriend. And I was very happy and in love and actually, very excited to share that with him and show him this wonderful life I had now.
大约五年前，他来法国看我，当时我和女友住在一起。我非常幸福，处于恋爱中，事实上，我很兴奋能和他分享这一切，向他展示我现在美好的生活。
And he was incredibly judgmental and said, well, the Bible does not abide by people of the same sex living with each other or loving each other. And he didn't actually want to stay with us. We went and stayed somewhere else and left him the apartment because that's the only way it would work.
但他却极其审判，他说，嗯，圣经是不容许同性恋者住在一起或相爱的。他其实不想和我们待在一起。我们不得不去别的地方住，把公寓留给他，因为那是唯一可行的方法。
So I think I cut him out of my life at that point, I just tried to forget that he was ever part of my life. So then he was gone again.
所以我认为我在那一刻把他从我的生活中剔除了，我只是试着忘记他曾是我生活的一部分。然后他就又走了。
I mean, very simply, I missed my brother. At some point, I realized I had a brother once, and I no longer do. I just started to feel like this is really sad and maybe it doesn't have to be like this. Now that he's born-again Christian, there will always be a huge divide between us. But the question became, even with that divide, did I want to try to have some kind of relationship? And I guess the answer was yes, or at least yes, I want to try, even though it might not work.
简单来说，我想念我的哥哥。在某个时刻，我意识到我曾经有个哥哥，而现在没有了。我开始觉得这真的很悲伤，也许不必如此。现在他是重生基督徒，我们之间永远会有巨大的鸿沟。但问题变成了，即便有这个鸿沟，我还想试着建立某种关系吗？我想答案是肯定的，或者至少是肯定的，我想试一试，尽管可能不会成功。
I decided to go visit Marc in Alaska. What happens is, you fly for a good 20, 25 minutes and you don't see anything, you're just in the hinterland of Alaska where nobody lives. And then, all of a sudden, there's a few little cabins down below. And you land on this airport that's basically just one landing strip. It's about as long as your average suburban mall parking lot. And then you're there.
我决定去阿拉斯加看望马克。在那儿，你会飞行足足20、25分钟，却什么也看不到，你只是在阿拉斯加没人居住的内陆地区。然后，突然之间，下面会出现几间小屋。你降落在那个基本上只有一条跑道的机场。它大约和普通郊区商场的停车场一样长。然后你就到了。
Oh, that so smooth!
噢，真平稳！
You look familiar.
你看起来很面熟。
Hi.
嗨。
Have we met?
我们见过吗？
Some time a long time ago.
很久以前见过。
This other plane pulled up just two seconds ago and everybody gets out. I'm like, "Hmm, I wonder."
另一架飞机两秒前才停下，每个人都下来了。我心想：“嗯，我想知道。”
Oh, no.
噢，不。
She missed the flight.
她错过了航班。
For many years, I lied about what Marc was doing in Alaska. I used to say that he was a scientist or that he was studying fish farming. I made up a whole bunch of weird things just because I didn't really understand why he was there myself. And I couldn't explain it to other people. And whenever I did say he was part of a born-again Christian community, people would say, "Oh, it's cult." And I didn't know what to say, so I just didn't tell people for a long time.
很多年来，我对于马克在阿拉斯加做什么撒了谎。我常说他是个科学家，或者说他在研究养鱼。我编造了一堆奇怪的事情，只是因为我自己真的不明白他为什么在那。而且我无法向别人解释。每当我提到他是重生基督徒社区的一员时，人们就会说：“噢，那是邪教。”我不知道该说什么，所以很长一段时间我都没有告诉别人。
And many people didn't even know I had a brother. I had a lot of friends I'd had for many years who would say, "Oh my God, you have a brother? I had no idea." So I think what I'd come to try to find out in visiting Marc after all those years was how he'd gone from being my brother, who I went to Hebrew school with and watched him prepare for his bar mitzvah, and how he had made this incredible transformation. What is he doing there and how can I try to understand it better? And would he still feel like my brother?
很多人甚至不知道我有哥哥。我有很多认识多年的朋友会说：“天哪，你有哥哥？我完全不知道。”所以我想，在多年后拜访马克，我是想弄清楚他是如何从我一起上希伯来学校、看着他准备受戒礼的哥哥，转变成现在这样令人难以置信的样子。他在那里做什么？我该怎么试着去更好地理解它？他还会像我哥哥吗？
There we go. Luke 18:30.
好了，就是这儿。路加福音18:30。
When do you like to read the Bible? Before you go to sleep?
你喜欢什么时候读圣经？睡觉前吗？
Yeah. That's what I usually do. Unfortunately, it doesn't last too long because I usually fall asleep within 10 seconds, but--
对。我通常都这样。不幸的是，它持续不了太久，因为我通常10秒内就睡着了，但是——
Do you like to talk about the scripture and try to figure out what they meant by stuff? Is it also an intellectual activity for you?
你喜欢讨论经文并试图弄清楚里面提到的东西吗？这对你来说也是一种智力活动吗？
Oh, no. Not really.
噢，不。并不是。
I was always jealous of Marc because he was very naturally talented. He was very creative and read a lot and was very intellectually engaged from an early age. Went to see old movies and that's just not interesting to him anymore.
我一直很嫉妒马克，因为他天赋很高。他很有创造力，读了很多书，很早就开始进行深度的智力交流。去看老电影，这些对他来说已经不再有趣了。
Well, what would heaven be like? Because I have no concept of that. I have tried to imagine that because when Dad died, I definitely tried to think about where is he? And that's probably the last time I thought about there maybe being a God.
那么，天堂会是什么样子？因为我一点概念都没有。我试着想象过，因为爸爸去世时，我确实试图想过他在哪里。那可能是我最后一次考虑可能存在上帝的时候了。
Yeah, right. Well, I really don't know what to answer. Let's just see when we look up about heaven, paradise.
对，没错。嗯，我真的不知道该怎么回答。让我们查查有关天堂、乐园的内容看看。
Well, I want to know what you think.
嗯，我想知道你的想法。
Well, what I think is-- if I have anything to say, it's going to be based on what the Bible says anyway, because there isn't really any other way to know except what's written in the Bible.
嗯，我的想法是——如果我有任何要说的，那也是基于圣经所说的，因为除了圣经所写的，真的没有其他途径可以得知。
Well, no. You think plenty of things that aren't exactly what's written in the Bible.
好吧，不。你肯定有很多想法并不完全是书上写的那些。
Well, yeah, I know. But where am I going to get an idea of what heaven is like? I mean, I've never been there. I don't really know.
嗯，对，我知道。但我能从哪得到天堂是什么样子的想法呢？我是说，我从来没去过。我真的不知道。
Yeah, but you can imagine.
是的，但你可以想象。
Yeah, but that's what I'm saying. What I'm saying is, what I would have to say would hopefully be based on what the Bible has to say. And if what I'm saying is my imagination, then it's kind of irrelevant anyway. Does that make sense?
是的，但这就是我想说的。我想说的是，我要说的话最好是基于圣经所说的。如果我所说的只是我的想象，那也就不相关了。这样说得通吗？
Yeah, but it feels more irrelevant to me if you just look up something and read it to me out of a book than if you tell me how you feel about it.
是的，但对我来说，如果你只是查一查然后从书里读给我听，这比你告诉我你的感受更让人觉得不相关。
But how I feel about it is based on what's in the book and I'm not sure exactly-- I haven't memorized the book, so I need to just look it up and see what it says.
但我的感受是基于书中的内容的，我不确定确切——我没背下整本书，所以我需要查一下看看上面写什么。
But it does seem like heaven is one of those things where-- I mean, what's it going to say? It's going to say there is a heaven and you all get to go there. But it's not going to tell you what it looks like. It's not going to say--
但这看起来天堂是那种——我是说，它会写什么？它会说有天堂，你们都能去那。但它不会告诉你天堂长什么样。它不会说——
Well, it doesn't tell you what it looks like.
嗯，它没说它长什么样。
Well, exactly. So why look it up?
嗯，正是如此。所以为什么要查它呢？
I want to see if it says anything that might be relevant.
我想看看它是否提到了任何相关的内容。
You can't look it up!
你不能查这个！
We're talking about heaven. If we read scriptures about heaven, it might give us more things to talk about.
我们在谈论天堂。如果我们读关于天堂的经文，可能会给我们更多讨论的话题。
I know, but asking you what you think of heaven was not connected to looking at scripture because those are two different things.
我知道，但问你对天堂的想法与查看经文无关，因为那是两回事。
Well, for me, it's connected to looking up scripture.
嗯，对我来说，这与查看经文有关。
Fine, look it up!
好吧，查吧！
No, now I don't want to.
不，现在我不想了。
How would you feel, though, if you asked me something and I said, "I don't know. I have to go look it up."
不过，如果你问我什么，我说“我不知道，我得去查查”，你会怎么想？
That wouldn't bother me in the least.
那对我一点影响都没有。
In The Feminist Guidebook . In The Lesbian Love Handbook of Life. But really, you've read it at some point, so something made an impression on you. And then you made a decision about which part you think is what you believe. I mean, some people believe in rapture. You don't believe in rapture.
在《女性主义指南》里？在《女同性恋爱情生活手册》里？但真的，你读过它，所以有些东西给你留下了印象。然后你决定了你认为哪部分是你相信的。我是说，有些人相信被提。你不相信被提。
No.
不。
So all I'm saying is, no matter what it says in here, you must have your own opinion.
所以我只是说，无论上面写了什么，你肯定有你自己的看法。
Yes, I do.
是的，我有。
And that's what I'm interested in.
那才是我感兴趣的。
But I'm  going to say exactly the same thing I just said five minutes ago. My opinion is based on this, and so that's why I want to look it up because it'll refresh my memory and give me some more ideas instead of just saying something off the top of my head about what little bit I remember.
但我说的话会和我五分钟前说的一模一样。我的观点基于此，所以我才想查阅它，因为它会刷新我的记忆并给我更多想法，而不是仅凭我对这书的一点点记忆随意乱说。
Yeah, I guess I just think it's a personal thing.
是的，我猜我只是认为这是件私人的事情。
It is a personal thing, but that's fine. That doesn't make any--
它是件私人的事，但这没关系。这并不能——
But do you have any personal zone left that's not the Bible?
但你还有任何不属于圣经的私人空间吗？
I think you're getting off track.
我觉得你跑题了。
It's a question.
这是一个问题。
No, I really do. I really do. I'm not sure why we're--
不，真的。真的。我不确定为什么我们——
Well, I guess I just  feel like--
嗯，我猜我只是觉得——
You're losing your objective--
你失去了你的客观——
I'm not objective.
我不客观。
I know. Well, you're losing your-- what's your job is called?
我知道。嗯，你失去了你的——你的工作叫什么来着？
Documenting?
记录？
Yes, totally. You really are. You're not working with me.
对，完全是。你真的是。你没在配合我。
OK. OK, let's look it up.
好。好，我们查查吧。
OK. I really thought there's really nothing wrong with looking it up.
好。我真的认为查一下没什么不对的。
No, there's nothing wrong with looking it up.
不，查一下没任何问题。
OK, totally nothing wrong with this. I'm going to look it up. OK, heaven.
好，完全没问题。我要查一下。好，天堂。
We are now looking up heaven in the Bible.
我们现在正在圣经里查天堂。
Exactly, just to see what it has to say. Not because I can't think for myself, but because [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
没错，只是看看它怎么说。不是因为我不能独立思考，而是因为[难以辨认]。
I think the most surprising thing to me was how much, even with his new views and how different he was, how the same he was also. I mean, we went running together around The Farm and we picked blueberries and then I made blueberry pancakes for everybody on The Farm. He played guitar and sang.
我觉得最让我惊讶的是，尽管他的观点变了，尽管他变得如此不同，但他其实还是原来的他。我是说，我们在“农场”周围跑步，摘蓝莓，然后我给农场里的每个人做了蓝莓煎饼。他弹吉他唱歌。
I got to listen to him. In a way, sometimes, I felt like he'd drawn this shade down over a window. But the window was still there and the shade was Christianity. But it was still him underneath. He was still sarcastic and he had a sense of humor. He was very caustic and self-deprecating. In a way, he really stood out on The Farm because he was the only one like that. I think that's the main thing that I found, is that we could still tease each other and be close.
我能听他唱歌。在某种程度上，有时我觉得他就像在窗户上拉下了一道帘子。但窗户还在，那帘子就是基督教。但帘子后面还是他。他依然爱讽刺人，依然有幽默感。他非常刻薄且善于自嘲。从某种程度上看，他在农场里真的很突出，因为他是唯一一个这样的人。我觉得这是我发现的最重要的一点，就是我们依然可以互相打趣，依然亲近。
I took a mean kick in the stomach for you.
我替你挨了一记狠的踢，踢在肚子上。
Did you really?
真的吗？
Don't you remember that? The bully who was twisting your nose?
你不记得了吗？那个扭你鼻子的恶霸？
No, I don't remember that.
不，我不记得了。
Because all the kids were so mean at the French school and you defended me.
因为法国学校里的孩子们都太刻薄了，你保护了我。
Yeah, that's true. We were, definitely, in a place where we needed to stick together. I remember beating up Jeanne for you.
是的，那倒是真的。我们确实处在一个需要抱团的地方。我记得我为了你揍了珍妮。
I remember that too. No, I do. I remember. She was--
我也记得。不，我知道。我记得。她——
Yeah, well, she was about as big as me, too. But I whooped her.
是的，她长得和我差不多大。但我狠狠教训了她。
I think, for so many years, my mother and maybe, to a degree, even I, felt responsible, in a way, for him having gone off to The Farm. And maybe that's why we didn't talk about it with other people and why I lied about it, is that, in some way, we felt it reflected badly on us as a family or somehow we had done something wrong, that he should want to trade in our family for this new spiritual family.
我想，多年来，我母亲，或许在某种程度上甚至是我，都因为他去了“农场”而感到某种责任感。也许这就是为什么我们不跟别人谈论它，为什么我撒谎，因为在某种程度上，我们觉得这让我们家看起来很糟糕，或者我们做错了什么，他才会想把我们的家庭换成这个新的属灵家庭。
But I think the irony is that, only in researching what happened to him and really, finally confronting the fact that he's there and trying to understand it, I think we've now realized that there's a lot that we didn't have anything to do with that has to do with Marc and his life and his demons that he's fighting. I mean, it was only in researching what had brought him to The Farm that I found out things about him that I had no idea, especially about the time that he was in college in Berkeley.
但我觉得讽刺的是，直到研究了他的经历，真正面对他就在那儿的事实并试图理解它，我才意识到很多事情是我们无法左右的，这与马克和他一生中所对抗的恶魔有关。我是说，只有在研究了是什么让他来到“农场”时，我才发现了关于他的事，我以前一无所知，尤其是在他在伯克利上大学的时候。
This is something I very rarely talk about because who wants to dredge up this kind of stuff? But really, over about six months-- I didn't get the time period right. It was more like a year. That whole year, I just went totally downhill. I remember taking a class in biology, your basic Bio 101, and I just couldn't hack it. I don't know what happened exactly-- I mean, I can tell you what happened. I don't know why. Or I can't explain it.
这是我很少谈论的事，因为谁想挖掘这类事情呢？但真的，大概六个月的时间里——我不确定时间段是否准确，大概一年吧。整整一年，我彻底陷入了低谷。我记得上了一门生物课，基础生物101，我根本学不下去。我不知道具体发生了什么——我是说，我可以告诉你发生了什么。但我不知道为什么。或者我无法解释。
I'll tell you what happened, is I took the class and got the book. It's like this. And I opened the book and I just couldn't do it. And that had never happened before, that I would set myself to something and not be able to do it. It was like something up here was going wrong, like some wires were getting crossed or something. It was very scary, actually. Very scary, I remember now. I'd really lost my mind. I mean, I can say it straight out. I had lost it completely. And the person I probably talked to the most during all this time about what was going on was Donna Austin.
我来告诉你发生了什么，是我上了课，拿到了书。就像这样。我打开书，但我就是做不到。这以前从没发生过，我定了目标却做不到。感觉就像这里出了问题，就像线路接错了一样。其实很可怕。非常可怕，我现在想起来。我真的疯了。我是说，我可以直说。我彻底崩溃了。而在这段期间，我谈论最多的人是唐娜·奥斯汀。
Oh, he would call and we'd spend two or three hours on the phone. That was the year that everything really fell apart for him emotionally, and mentally too, I think.
噢，他会打电话，我们会在电话里聊上两三个小时。那一年，他的情感和心理真的彻底崩溃了，我想。
Donna Austin is sort of my brother's surrogate mother on The Farm. She is the first person he had contact with there and who is one of the people who convinced him to move there and to stay.
唐娜·奥斯汀算是我哥哥在“农场”的代理母亲。她是他到那里后第一个有接触的人，也是劝说他搬去那里并留下来的人之一。
We had given him a Bible and he was reading his Bible. And it was soon after that that he had this very unusual experience in the way that The Holy Ghost filled him and gave him the baptism of The Holy Ghost. He had gotten involved with a Church of Christ group there, and they were telling that he wasn't saved and that because of this and that and his doctrines-- which he didn't even know about, anyway-- and because of his experiences, he just really wasn't saved.
我们送了他一本圣经，他在读圣经。没过多久，他就有了那种非常不寻常的经历，圣灵充满了他，让他领受了圣灵的洗礼。他参与了那里的基督教会小组，他们告诉他他还没得救，因为这因为那，因为他的教义——他自己甚至都不知道这些教义——并且因为他的经历，他实际上并没有得救。
So he was in conflict with those that were Christians that were guiding him. And then he also just had thoughts that he was a complete failure and he couldn't make it with God and so he said, "God, you've got to meet me or I'm just not going to go on. I don't know what I'm going to do with myself. So one night, he went over to a park of some kind.
所以他与指导他的基督徒产生了冲突。然后他还产生了一些想法，认为自己是个彻底的失败者，他无法与上帝同行，所以他说：“上帝，你必须见我，否则我真的活不下去了。我不知道自己会做什么。”所以一天晚上，他去了某个公园。
There was like some hills right around Berkeley, just walking distance. So I just walked up to the top of this hill. And it was evening. It was starting to get dark. And I just knew that I was going to be there until I had my answer. I knew I had to have the answer.
伯克利附近有一些山丘，走路就能到。所以我只是走到山顶。那时是傍晚。天开始黑了。我知道我会一直待在那里，直到我得到答案。我知道我必须得到答案。
He had been on his knees, I think, most of the night, in the dark, at the top of some kind of a hill. And I don't know what his thinking was, but he took some rocks and hit himself on the head, thinking, "I'm either going to knock some sense into myself or kill myself, one or the other." Hit himself with rocks.
我想他在黑暗的山顶上跪了几乎一整晚。我不知道他在想什么，但他拿起一些石头砸自己的头，心想：“要么我把自己砸清醒，要么砸死自己，二选一。”他用石头砸自己。
Basically, I threw myself off the edge of this cliff. Not a big cliff, but I was to the point where I was either going to die or find God trying. It was a real confused state of mind, but essentially, I did. I threw myself off the edge and wound up at the bottom of this precipice-- minor, slight precipice. I was a little bit worse for wear, but I wasn't in too bad shape.
基本上，我把自己从悬崖边扔了下去。不是大悬崖，但我当时的想法是，要么死，要么在寻找上帝的过程中尝试。那是一种非常混乱的状态，但本质上，我确实做了。我从边缘扔下自己，最后落到了悬崖底部——小小的、稍微陡峭的斜坡。我受了点轻伤，但没受太重的伤。
And I just kept praying. I said, "God, I don't know the answer. You've got to show me." And I stayed there pretty much until, I don't know, it was like 3:00 in the morning, 4:00 in the morning. And at one point, I was just on my knees and I was just waiting. And I was just waiting, not expecting anything in particular. But all of a sudden, something inside me just started welling up. And it was kind of like a joyful feeling, but really joyful. Something was-- I don't know-- a kind of warm feeling, and I started speaking in tongues, just like that. It just came out.
我只是不停地祈祷。我说：“上帝，我不知道答案。你必须向我展示。”我一直待在那儿，直到，我不知道，大概凌晨3点或4点。有那么一刻，我跪着，我在等待。我只是等待，没期待任何特别的事情。但突然之间，我内心深处涌出了一些东西。那感觉有点像喜悦，非常喜悦。有些东西——我不知道——一种温暖的感觉，我开始说方言，就这样。它自然而然地出来了。
And I was like, "Whoa, this must be speaking in tongues." And I just, once again, felt the presence of God and I was just so happy. I felt the presence of the Holy Spirit in a way that was like the way we're sitting here, like you're here. And I knew what he was saying. He was saying, "Don't worry. Everything's going to be all right."
我心想：“哇，这一定是说方言。”那一刻，我又一次感受到了上帝的同在，我太开心了。我感受到了圣灵的同在，就像我们坐在这里一样，就像你在这里一样。我知道他在说什么。他说：“别担心。一切都会好起来的。”
I was really shocked to hear how depressed and desperate he was in Berkeley. I had never known that he was that bad off. And I try not to spend too much time thinking about how it all could have turned out differently, but I think, after hearing about how in distress he was at Berkeley, I realized that The Farm saved his life in some ways. And I think some of the resentment I felt about him being there got replaced with a kind of gratitude that people took him in and took care of him at a time when he didn't or couldn't or wouldn't turn to us. So I think that changed my attitude towards The Farm.
听到他在伯克利是多么绝望和困顿，我真的很震惊。我从未知道他当时那么糟糕。我尽量不去花太多时间思考这一切本可以如何有不同的结果，但在听到他在伯克利是多么痛苦后，我意识到“农场”在某种程度上救了他的命。我想我对他待在那儿的一些怨恨，被一种感激之情所取代，因为当他不想、不能或不会向我们求助时，有人接纳并照顾了他。所以我想这改变了我对“农场”的态度。
Sometimes, it seems like you worked out your issues through religion and I worked out my issues through therapy.
有时，看起来你通过宗教解决了你的问题，而我通过治疗解决了我的问题。
Right.
对。
I guess one thing that I was thinking about that we talked about yesterday is I guess I felt it was important to me that you still have respect for my system of belief and that if I were to seek psychological counsel or have problems that I thought were due to psychological factors, whatever they may be, that I wasn't sure how you would see that. Like, if you see all work as the work of evil spirits trying to pull you down or if you think that people really can have psychological problems.
我想有一件事我们昨天谈过，我想我感觉到对我来说很重要的一点是，你仍然尊重我的信仰体系。如果我寻求心理咨询，或者遇到我认为是由于心理因素——无论它们是什么——引起的问题，我不确定你会怎么看。比如，你是否将所有的努力都看作是试图压垮你的邪灵所为，或者你是否认为人们真的会有心理问题。
Well, there's a natural realm of just the things that God's created. And within that natural realm, there are laws and so things are going to work for people, and working on dealing with your emotions and so on. But the spiritual realm, it's really above all that.
嗯，上帝创造的事物有一个自然的领域。在这个自然领域内，有法则存在，所以人们会努力处理情绪等等。但属灵的领域，它确实在这一切之上。
But if I were really depressed, would you be thinking it was spirits or what would you think?
但如果我真的很抑郁，你会认为这是邪灵吗，还是你会怎么想？
You're really stuck on this spirit thing.
你真的被这“邪灵”的事给卡住了。
Yeah, because I don't get it. I don't get it. I don't believe in them. And I was wondering if you're-- OK, you know what else I'm thinking of? I'm thinking of the fact that I did feel like, in high school, like you always felt very superior and was looking down on what I was doing. And the irony of this whole conversation is that part of me is this big flashback to high school. That you're like, "Well, you can do whatever you want down there--"
是的，因为我不明白。我不明白。我不相信它们。我只是在想你是否——好，你知道我还想到什么吗？我想到高中时，我确实感觉到你总是表现得非常优越，看不起我正在做的事情。而这次谈话的讽刺之处在于，我的一部分经历就像是高中的大闪回。就像你在说：“好吧，你在那下面想做什么都行——”
On that lower realm, yeah.
在较低的自然领域里，是的。
--in the natural realm because we're up here in the spiritual realm.
——因为我们处于属灵的领域。
Yeah, right. Well, that's always my hesitation about talking about any of this because I just don't know how to relate it to you without it being something that you're going to say, "This is weird," or "I can't deal with this," or "I can't understand this."
嗯，对。好吧，这就是我总是犹豫要不要谈论这些的原因，因为我不知道如何跟你沟通，才不会让你说：“这很奇怪”，或者“我无法处理这个”，或者“我无法理解这个”。
It's not that this is weird, it's the "I know better."
不是因为这很奇怪，而是那种“我知道得更好”的态度。
Yeah, OK. Well, unfortunately, it can come off extremely arrogant to say, well, this is the way, the truth, and the life. And that's what Jesus said. "I am the way, the truth, and the life." And you can't water it down and you can't make it acceptable. And it divides people.
是的，好。好吧，不幸的是，说这是道路、真理和生命，可能会显得极其傲慢。这就是耶稣所说的。“我就是道路、真理和生命。”你不能淡化它，你不能让它变得顺耳。它确实会把人分开。
But you see that I'm struggling to accept that your way is a valid way that's just different from my way. And I want to feel like you also feel that my way is a valid way. It's just different from your way. I know you don't think that.
但你看得出我正在努力接受你的方式是一种有效的、只是不同于我的方式。我也希望你觉得我的方式也是一种有效的方式。它只是不同于你的方式。我知道你不是这么想的。
Well, there just isn't room for that. We can't really--
嗯，那里没有这种空间。我们不能真正——
Communicate.
交流。
Not really.
并不完全能。
In our day-to-day relationship, sometimes, we can actually forget that he's born again and I'm a secular Jew. But then we stumble on these land mines that really explode into conflict between us.
在我们日常的关系中，有时我们真的可以忘记他是重生基督徒，而我是个世俗的犹太人。但随后我们就会踩到这些地雷，在我们之间引发冲突。
I would never be able to say, "Yes, I'm happy that you're having this lesbian lifestyle." I could never say that. But that still doesn't change that you are my sister and I care about you just as much as I always have and still consider you my sister. Those two things are both true. It's going to be a brick wall because there's no way. There's no middle ground. There just isn't.
我永远无法说：“是的，我很高兴你过着这种女同性恋的生活。”我永远说不出这话。但那并不改变你是我的姐妹这一事实，我依然像以往一样在乎你，依然把你当成我的姐妹。这两件事都是事实。这将会是一道砖墙，因为根本没有办法。没有中间地带。根本没有。
Part of me didn't even buy that he felt that way because he had had plenty of friends who were gay and bisexual. And I'm not sure if he experimented or not in that vein, but he certainly was not someone who was homophobic or concerned about people's sexual orientation. So the idea that he adopted this set of values that included homophobia when he wasn't homophobic himself was just very irritating. It did feel like he was spouting something that had been fed to him.
我的一部分甚至不相信他是那样想的，因为他有很多朋友是同性恋和双性恋。我不确定他在那方面是否有过尝试，但他绝对不是恐同的人，也不关心人们的性取向。所以他采纳了这套包含恐同内容的价值观，而他本人并非恐同，这真的让人非常恼火。这感觉就像他在背诵别人喂给他的话。
Well, the Bible says God's put His laws in our hearts. And maybe that's why, because what you're doing is against the law of God, as it's written in the Bible, flat out, and it's in my heart. And so it goes against what's in my heart. And that's why, maybe it's something that I can feel.
嗯，圣经说上帝把律法放在了我们心里。也许这就是为什么，因为你所做的事违反了圣经中明确记载的上帝的律法，它在我心里。所以它违背了我心里的东西。也许这就是为什么，这是一种我可以感受到的事情。
Yeah, yeah. I mean, I think it was--
是的，是的。我是说，我认为那是——
When I came to this thing of accepting Christianity, it wasn't that I read the Bible and decided, OK, I agree that a man is made a man and a woman is made a woman and they're made that way by God and anything else is a perversion. It's not like I read that and I read some of the other doctrines and said, "This is what I want. I agree with this. This is right." I accepted Jesus and what comes along with that is what's written in His word.
当我来到接受基督教这一步时，并不是说我读了圣经然后决定，好，我同意男人被造为男人，女人被造为女人，他们是由上帝这样创造的，任何其他形式都是一种变态。并不是我读了这些，读了一些其他教义，然后说：“这是我想要的。我同意这个。这是正确的。”我接受了耶稣，随之而来的是他话语中所写的一切。
I don't know what would happen if I was with a woman and we want to come visit you.
我不知道如果我和一个女人在一起，我们想来看你，会发生什么。
I mean, I can't say it's right, it's fine, no big deal. Because it is a big deal.
我是说，我不能说这是对的，没关系，没什么大不了的。因为它确实是大问题。
These are the things that no longer freak me out when I think about Marc, that he talks in tongues, that he has to check with God before he makes any move at all, that he believes that there's a destiny and that God has his all planned out and he just has to live according to what it is.
这些事情当我想到马克时不再让我抓狂了，他说方言，他在做任何决定前必须向上帝确认，他相信命运，上帝已经安排好了一切，他只需要按照那个去生活。
You would naturally think I'd be praying for their salvation and be praying for God to touch them the way he touched me and want them to be Christian. And a few years ago, I was thinking, "Wouldn't it be neat if Julia was Christian and lived on The Farm and I had my sister here and my family here and my mom and wouldn't that be wonderful if we all agreed and they were on my side?"
你自然会认为我会为他们的救赎祈祷，为上帝能以他触碰我的方式触碰他们而祈祷，希望他们成为基督徒。几年前，我还在想：“如果朱莉娅能成为基督徒，住在这个农场，我有我的姐妹在这里，有我的家庭在这里，还有我妈妈，如果我们大家都一致同意，他们站在我这一边，那该多好啊？”
And then, at other times, I've thought, "What, really, do I have to offer? Julia's a wonderful person and has wonderful friends and has a life that she's, I believe, fulfilled with and does good things for people. And what's the point of praying for them? What does God have to offer them? Or not, what does God have to offer them, but I don't see the need there. I don't see that they'd be any happier if they became Christian.
然后，在其他时候，我想过：“我到底能提供什么？朱莉娅是一个很好的人，有很好的朋友，有一个我认为很充实的生活，并且为人们做好事。为他们祈祷有什么意义呢？上帝能给他们提供什么？或者说，不是上帝能提供什么，我根本看不出有什么必要。我不觉得如果他们成为基督徒会更快乐。”
And that's actually ironic, that all these years, he's taken us on our own terms and hasn't preached and we really didn't take him on his terms until very recently. And I think one of the hardest things I had to do was accept that Marc would never be the brother I grew up with. He would never be the same as he was before. And I had to relearn to love him, in a way. He was a whole different person now.
讽刺的是，这些年来，他一直以我们自己的方式对待我们，没有传教，而我们直到最近才以他的方式对待他。我觉得我必须做的最困难的事情之一，就是接受马克永远不会再是我小时候成长的那个哥哥了。他永远不会像以前一样。在某种程度上，我不得不重新学会爱他。他现在完全是另一个人。
Julia Pimsleur and her brother, Marc Pimsleur. The audio recordings in our story are from a film documentary that she made about her visit to see Marc in Alaska called Brother Born Again. It's available on the internet at artsengine.net.
朱莉娅·平斯勒和她的哥哥马克·平斯勒。我们故事中的音频记录来自她为探访在阿拉斯加的马克而拍摄的纪录片，名为《重生哥哥》。可以在网上artsengine.net观看。
In the eight years since we first put this story of the air, Marc has left Alaska to medical school in Texas. He's now in his first year of residency. He is still a Christian. He is still affiliated with The Farm. In the eight years since Julia made her film, she's gotten married-- to a man, a rabbi, in fact. The have two kids.
在我们首次播出这个故事的八年时间里，马克已经离开了阿拉斯加，去了得克萨斯州的医学院。他现在是第一年实习医生。他依然是基督徒。他依然隶属于“农场”。在朱莉娅制作她的电影后的八年里，她结婚了——事实上，嫁给了一个男人，一位拉比。他们有两个孩子。
[MUSIC--"IN THE LINES" BY PORTASTATIC]
[音乐——Portastatic的《In the Lines》]
Coming up, matching light blue easy chairs with matching teddy bears sitting on them and what else can happen if your relationship with your brothers and sisters does stay the same as it was when you were kids. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，有着配套泰迪熊的同款浅蓝色休闲椅，如果你的兄弟姐妹关系确实和你们小时候保持得一模一样，还会发生什么呢？再过一分钟，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Nobody's Family is Going to Change.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为你带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目是《没人能改变家庭》。
We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Matching Outfits Not Included. In this act, we consider the question, what if your relationships with your loved ones, your brothers and sisters, never changes? Hillary Frank has this story of two sisters-- grown women-- who go by the nicknames that they were given as little girls, Dusty and Honey.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“不含配套服装”。在这一幕里，我们思考这样一个问题：如果你们与挚爱、兄弟姐妹的关系从来没有改变，会怎样？希拉里·弗兰克带来了这个关于一对姐妹——成年女性——的故事，她们用着小时候被起的昵称，达斯蒂和哈妮。
Back when Dusty and Honey were in their early 20s, not long after World War II, they were shopping in a store called Lerner's. They were looking for clothes on opposite sides of a circular rack and found that they both picked the same outfit, a green corduroy two-piece sports suit. They left the store dressed identically and have been dressing alike ever since.
早年，在达斯蒂和哈妮20出头时，二战刚结束不久，她们在一家叫Lerner's的店里购物。她们在圆形衣架的两侧找衣服，发现她们都选了同一套，一套绿色灯芯绒两件套运动服。她们穿着一模一样的衣服离开了店，从那以后就一直穿得一样。
Right now, I've got on what I call my fatigue outfits. I did my exercise. I've got a pair of brown shorts and a white-- where'd I get this? Someone sent this-- oh, from Cape Cod.
现在，我穿着我所谓的“疲劳服”。我刚锻炼完。我穿着棕色短裤和一件白色——我从哪得到的？有人寄来的——噢，来自科德角。
And Honey, what are you wearing?
哈妮，你穿什么？
I'm wearing the same thing Dusty is-- the brown shorts and the Cape Cod T-shirt.
我穿的跟达斯蒂一样——棕色短裤和科德角T恤。
People say, "Why do you--" Well, we have the same taste in clothes. So if I like the same thing she has, I want it. So we both wear it.
人们问，“你们为什么——”嗯，我们在衣服上的品味一样。所以如果她有的东西我喜欢，我就想要。所以我们就都穿它。
And wearing the same clothes alike all the time, well, I can't say well, she's wearing my skirt or she's wearing my blouse because it'll be the same thing. We're happy dressing alike.
穿着一模一样的衣服，好吧，我不能说，她是穿了我的裙子还是衬衫，因为那是一样的东西。我们穿着一样的衣服很高兴。
Dusty and Honey are sisters in their early 70s. They've lived together all their lives, mostly in Westport, Connecticut. They have the same wigs, the same eyeglasses, the same jewelry and purses. But Dusty and Honey aren't twins. Dusty is three years older than Honey. Their bedroom has two twin beds, piled with matching stuffed animals. Above each bed is a crucifix, and above those, centered in the middle, staring down, is a framed picture of Frank Sinatra.
达斯蒂和哈妮是70多岁的姐妹。她们一生都住在一起，大多在康涅狄格州的韦斯特波特。她们有一样的假发、一样的眼镜、一样的首饰和钱包。但达斯蒂和哈妮不是双胞胎。达斯蒂比哈妮大三岁。她们的卧室有两张双人床，堆满了同款毛绒玩具。每张床上方都有一个十字架，在它们中间，盯着看的是一张弗兰克·辛纳屈的相框照片。
Not only do Dusty and Honey eat the same food, but they make sure that one never has a larger portion than the other. And one will only have a treat if the other is there to share it with her.
达斯蒂和哈妮不仅吃一样的食物，而且确保一个人永远不会比另一个人分量多。只有另一个人在场共同分享时，一个人才会吃零食。
And if I'm out to the store, you know how sometime at a deli, they'll have samples, if she's not there with me to have a sample, I won't take it. I have to have her with me. I'll go get a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] there's a sample there, but I won't take it and not let her have it. That sounds strange to some people, but that's the way we are and you just can't change us.
如果我在店里，你知道有时在熟食店，他们会有样品，如果她不在我身边，我不会拿。我必须有她在身边。我会去拿一份[难以辨认]那里有个样品，但我不会拿走而不让她也吃一份。这在某些人听起来很奇怪，但我们就是这样，你没法改变我们。
But it works out fine. And as long as we like, we say we're not hurting anybody. Some people go, "Oh, it's--" We're not hurting anyone. We're not breaking a commandment. And that's the main thing.
但这没问题。只要我们喜欢，我们说我们没伤害任何人。有些人会说，“噢，这是——”我们没伤害任何人。我们没违背戒律。这是最主要的。
There's a kind of closeness between little girls who are best friends where it makes you feel secure and safe to think that there's someone who shares all the same likes and dislikes. All you want is to do everything together. Dusty and Honey have somehow managed to carry that kind of friendship into adulthood. They're like the girls who write "best friends forever" on the bathroom wall, except for them, the forever part is real.
小时候最好的朋友之间有一种亲密关系，让你觉得有个分享所有喜好和讨厌的人会感到安全。你想要的只是做一切事情都在一起。达斯蒂和哈妮不知何故设法将这种友谊带入了成年生活。她们就像那些在洗手间墙上写着“永远最好的朋友”的女孩，对她们来说，“永远”是真实的。
It can feel sort of strange visiting them in their house. Two matching women sitting on matching easy chairs in their living room, completing each other's sentences. Even in their jobs they've been together. First a sweatshop, then an elderly home. For 30 years, they worked as housekeepers for a local priest.
去她们家拜访会感觉有点奇怪。两个相貌相同的女人坐在起居室的同款休闲椅上，补全对方的句子。甚至在工作上她们也在一起。先是在血汗工厂，然后是养老院。30年来，她们一直为一位当地牧师当管家。
Is it ever hard to feel like you're a separate person?
感觉自己是个独立的个体很难吗？
A separate person?
独立的个体？
Yeah, I mean, you do everything together, right? And you dress the same and do you ever feel like you want to feel like just an individual?
是的，我是说，你们一起做每件事，对吧？你们穿得一样，你有没有想过感觉自己只是个个人？
A different person? If I do that, I think I'm hurting her. It's like I don't love her anymore. I don't want to do anything with her. I couldn't do that. They say, "Why don't you dress differently than your sister?" No, then I'll hurt her. I feel like I don't love her anymore and I couldn't do that to her. That would be like betraying her.
不同的人？如果我那样做，我觉得我伤害了她。就像我不再爱她了。我不想和她做任何事。我做不到。他们说，“为什么你不穿得跟你姐姐不一样？”不，那样我会伤她的心。我感觉我不再爱她了，我不能那样对她。那就像背叛她。
They know their relationship is unusual. But when I asked them why it turned out this way, they just say over and over that this is what was meant to be, and this is what makes them happy. They learned to depend on each other as little girls growing up during The Depression, the youngest of six children, often going to bed hungry and cold. Their father died when Honey was two and Dusty was five.
她们知道自己的关系很不寻常。但我问她们为什么会变成这样时，她们一遍又一遍地说，这就是命中注定的，这就是让她们快乐的原因。她们在经济大萧条时期成长，是六个孩子中最小的两个，学会了互相依赖，经常饿着肚子挨冻。她们的父亲在哈妮两岁、达斯蒂五岁时去世了。
Dusty was always sort of fragile. For a long time, whenever Dusty and Honey went out, Honey found herself doing everything for Dusty because Dusty was too shy to do things herself. Dusty and Honey lived at home through their early 30s and cared for their ailing mother. They watched their older siblings get married, one by one.
达斯蒂总是比较脆弱。很长一段时间，无论达斯蒂和哈妮去哪，哈妮都发现自己不得不为达斯蒂做一切，因为达斯蒂太害羞，自己不敢做事。达斯蒂和哈妮在家住到30出头，照顾生病的母亲。她们看着年长的兄弟姐妹一个接一个结婚。
And every time they got married, there was the living room, and they had a door that went right out to the hallway. And they used to go out there with their gowns. So after they got married, my mother sealed that door up. I said, "Ma, you're trying to tell us we're never getting married and going out that door?" But she sealed that door up after Louise got married."
每当他们结婚，客厅里都会有一扇门通向走廊。他们过去常常穿着礼服从那里出去。所以在他们结婚后，我母亲把那扇门封死了。我说，“妈，你是在试图告诉我们，我们永远不会结婚从那扇门走出去吗？但露易丝结婚后，她确实封死了那扇门。”
Do you think your mother wanted you to get married?
你觉得你母亲想让你们结婚吗？
No. No, I can't say, like some mothers, when you go to get married, she never pressured us into that. Never, never. No. I guess she knew we were meant to stay with one another. It was just something, I guess, that's in the books. Nothing you could do about that.
不。不，我不能说，像有些母亲那样，当你去结婚时，她从没给我们施压。从没，从没。不。我猜她知道我们是命中注定要待在一起的。这只是某种——我猜，命中注定的事。关于这个你什么都做不了。
Do you think in some ways that this relationship is less complicated than married couples?
你觉得在某种程度上，这种关系比夫妻关系更不复杂吗？
Yeah, I think so. I think so. Because we understand one another and one doesn't try to hurt the other one or lie or cheat.
是的，我想是。我想是。因为我们了解对方，一个人不会试图伤害另一个人，或者撒谎、作弊。
That's a pretty bleak view of marriage. It turns out that much of Dusty and Honey's information about marriage comes from soap operas. For as long as they can remember, they've been either listening to soaps on the radio or watching them on television.
这对婚姻的看法真够灰暗的。事实证明，达斯蒂和哈妮对婚姻的大部分了解来自于肥皂剧。从她们记事起，她们就一直在收音机听或者电视看肥皂剧。
People say they're silly, but we enjoy them. Like I say, thank God I  don't live half of the lives they live.
人们说它们很傻，但我们很喜欢。像我说的，感谢上帝，我没过他们过的一半生活。
It's interesting because your lives seem to be very controlled and common. On the soap operas, they're very turbulent.
这很有趣，因为你们的生活看起来非常受控和普通。而在肥皂剧里，生活非常动荡。
That's what I mean. You watch all that, thinking you're so quiet. Well, that's how we get our kicks out of life, watching does everyone know the facts of life when we see TV. Because my mother didn't tell us anything. You bought a baby. You didn't have a baby, you bought a baby.
这就是我的意思。你看着这一切，觉得自己太安静了。嗯，这就是我们从生活中获得快感的方式，看电视时了解生活的真相。因为我母亲什么都没告诉我们。你是买了个婴儿。你不是生了个婴儿，你是买了个婴儿。
They describe themselves as young at heart, and I think that's a fair description. Their nieces have helped them keep up with teenybopper culture, Britney Spears and 'N SYNC and all the others.
她们描述自己心态年轻，我觉得这描述很贴切。她们的侄女帮她们跟上少女文化，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯和“超级男孩”之类的。
I like the way Ricky Martin moves. I wouldn't mind going out with him, we'd always say. If I was only 20 years younger.
我喜欢瑞奇·马丁的动作。我不介意跟他约会，我们总这么说。只要我年轻20岁就好了。
Dusty puts her hands up mambo style and does a little shake for me, a la Ricky Martin.
达斯蒂举起双手，模仿瑞奇·马丁的样子，给我做了个小小的扭动。
Every night, Dusty and Honey lay in their twin beds and talk before they fall asleep about what they're going to do the next day and what they'll wear and whether it'll be too cold for their Bermudas, like best friends on a sleepover that never ends.
每天晚上，达斯蒂和哈妮躺在双人床上，在睡前谈论明天要做什么，穿什么，以及百慕大短裤会不会太冷，就像一场永不结束的睡衣派对上的好朋友。
Hillary Frank is the author of the novels Better Than Running at Night and I Can't Tell You.
希拉里·弗兰克是小说《Better Than Running at Night》和《I Can't Tell You》的作者。
[MUSIC -- "LA VIDA LOCA" BY RICKY MARTIN]
[音乐——瑞奇·马丁的《La Vida Loca》]
Act Three, The Artist Formerly Known as Doctor Sarkin. Sometime in 1999, I'm not exactly sure when, I got in the mail a drawing of a head with six eyeballs, bared teeth, and in a word balloon above it, seven pairs of words, each of them anagrams of the letters of my own name. Ail Grass. Liars Sag. Sail Rags. Alas Rigs. Over time, I received a stack of artwork half a foot high, including a guitar-shaped wooden cutting board that somebody simply drew on, fixed some stamps to, and threw in the mail, plus a full canvas painting, plus dozens of pages of stream-of-consciousness poetry, all the work of one Jon Sarkin.
第三幕，“曾被称为萨金博士的艺术家”。1999年某个时候，我不确定具体时间，我收到了一封信，画着一个有六只眼睛、露出牙齿的头，上面的对话框里有七对词，每一对都是我名字的字母重排组合。Ail Grass（草之哀）。Liars Sag（骗子下垂）。Sail Rags（扬起破布）。Alas Rigs（唉，索具）。随着时间推移，我收到了一叠半英尺厚的艺术品，包括一个有人简单画过、粘了邮票扔进邮筒的吉他形状木制砧板，加上一幅完整的画布画，还有几十页意识流诗歌，全部出自乔恩·萨金之手。
He seemed sort of crazy, but not so crazy that he didn't provide perfectly organized press clippings about himself and his phone number and his web address. We talked a few times on the phone.
他看起来有点疯，但又不至于没提供关于他自己、电话号码和网页地址的完全有序的媒体报道。我们在电话里聊过几次。
I thought of Jon Sarkin when the idea for this week's show came up because his family had gone through a change-- a dramatic change-- but they'd stayed together. And now they all yearn for another change. Back in 1988, Jon was, as he puts it-- this is his phrase-- your classic, suburban, college-educated, professional, upper-middle-class Jew. Chiropractor with workaholic tendencies.
当本周节目的主题出现时，我想到了乔恩·萨金，因为他的家庭经历了一个转变——一个剧烈的转变——但他们仍然在一起。现在他们都渴望另一个改变。回溯到1988年，乔恩，用他自己的话说——这是他的口头禅——你是典型的、郊区的、受过大学教育的、专业的、中产阶级犹太人。一个有工作狂倾向的脊椎按摩师。
And on the golf course one day, something went wrong in his brain, which led to a stroke, and surgery where they removed part of the cerebellum, which unhinged something in his life. He wasn't able to do a normal job, and he started doing art, an obsessive, primitive sort of art that he did in an obsessive, primitive sort of way. Jon Sarkin sees double, the left side of his body's weak, he walks with a cane, he's deaf in the left ear.
有一天在高尔夫球场上，他的大脑出了点问题，导致了中风，手术中切除了部分小脑，这打乱了他生活中的某些东西。他无法从事正常工作，开始做艺术，一种他以强迫、原始方式进行的强迫性、原始艺术。乔恩·萨金视力重影，身体左侧无力，他拄着拐杖走动，左耳失聪。
But he's also lost a certain kind of everyday reasoning and thinking in a way that, as you might imagine, affects his family life. For instance, how he gets along with his son, Curtis, age 12.
但他同时也失去了一定程度的日常推理和思考能力，正如你所想，这影响了他的家庭生活。例如，他与12岁儿子柯蒂斯相处的方式。
The thing that just happened yesterday. We're going to the beach, and all the beach toys are in this big basket. So I take the basket out and Curtis says, "Put the basket back in the garage and we'll wait for mom." I'm like, OK. So I take the basket and I dump all the beach toys out and I put the basket back in the garage, just like he asked me to.
昨天发生的一件事。我们要去海滩，所有的海滩玩具都在那个大篮子里。我把篮子拿出来，柯蒂斯说：“把篮子放回车库，我们等妈妈。”我说，好吧。于是我拿着篮子，把所有的海滩玩具倒出来，按照他要求的那样把篮子放回车库。
And he's like, "Dad, what are you doing?"
他就像：“爸爸，你在做什么？”
I said, "You asked me to put the basket back in the garage, Curtis."
我说：“是你让我把篮子放回车库的，柯蒂斯。”
"Dad, with the beach toys."
“爸爸，连带海滩玩具一起。”
I'm so literal. Being highly literal gets you into trouble.
我太死板了。太过死板会让你陷入麻烦。
The world Jon's created for himself, a studio where he does his artwork in the seaside town of Gloucester, Massachusetts, is just a dirty little room with dingy junk everywhere. The world his wife has created for their family is a pretty, suburban-style house that's so immaculate, it's like a critique of where he works.
乔恩为自己创造的世界，一个他在马萨诸塞州格洛斯特海滨小镇的工作室，只是一个到处都是破烂的肮脏小房间。他妻子为家人创造的世界是一栋漂亮的郊区风格房子，一尘不染，简直是对他工作场所的批评。
At 12, Curtis is the oldest child, Robin's almost 9, and Caroline just turned 6. After family dinner one night, Jon's wife, Kim, and I sat on the front steps under the trees for an interview. Curtis comes out and they tell me how there are so many funny family stories about their dad.
12岁的柯蒂斯是长子，罗宾快9岁了，卡罗琳刚满6岁。一天家庭晚宴后，乔恩的妻子金和我坐在前台阶的树下接受采访。柯蒂斯走出来，他们告诉我关于他们父亲有多少有趣的家庭故事。
We could go way back. How far back do you want to go?
我们可以追溯很久以前。你想回溯到多远？
Mom, can I tell the French fry story?
妈妈，我能讲那个炸薯条的故事吗？
Yeah.
可以。
All right, back--
好的，回溯——
It's a story of how Jon insisted that they bring their leftover French fries home from Disney World in Florida so they could recycle them in the compost pile. Or the story about Jon trying to help unpack the kitchen when they moved to the house, but doing it in a completely random way, the way a toddler might. Or the story about Jon not noticing the Caroline got locked outside for a few cold minutes one winter. Each story takes such a disturbing turn that at one point, Kim says, "Let's say some positive things about Dad." Take this story.
这是一个关于乔恩坚持要他们把佛罗里达迪士尼乐园剩下的炸薯条带回家，这样他们就可以在堆肥堆里回收利用的故事。或者乔恩试图帮忙整理厨房但在搬家时以幼儿般极其随机的方式进行的故事。或者乔恩没注意到卡罗琳被锁在外面受冻了几分钟的故事。每个故事的转折都如此令人不安，以至于在某个时刻，金说：“让我们说说关于爸爸积极的事情。”拿这个故事来说。
Tell about-- what was I going to say? When he first came home from the hospital, wasn't he laughing like crazy over Mickey Mouse cartoons?
讲讲——我刚才想说什么来着？他第一次从医院回家时，不是对着米老鼠卡通片笑得像疯了一样吗？
I had a moments where Curtis was sitting on the couch watching cartoons. And he was about two.
我有过柯蒂斯坐在沙发上看卡通片的时刻。他当时大概两岁。
Mickey Mouse.
米老鼠。
Mickey Mouse. And Jon was sitting on the floor and he was roaring with laughter over these Mickey Mouse cartoons. I mean roaring. And I thought to myself, "Oh, God. What have I brought home?" Because he was like a little kid. And living with Jon at that time was like living with a teenager, the way teenagers are explosive and irrational and moody. He was all those things and I was the mom. So that was a tough time, but he did continue to get better.
米老鼠。乔恩坐在地板上，看着那些米老鼠卡通片狂笑不止。我是说咆哮。我心想：“噢，上帝。我带回了一个什么人？”因为他就像个小孩子。那时候和乔恩一起生活就像和一个青少年一起生活，青少年那种爆发性、不理性、情绪化的方式。他就是那样，而我是妈妈。所以那段日子很难熬，但他确实在继续好转。
Do you feel like, in some ways, though, he still is like a teenager and you're still like--
你觉得在某种程度上，他还是像个青少年，而你还是像——
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
Curtis says he was seven or eight when he understood the extent to which his dad wasn't like the other dads. And when he'd complain about his father, Robin, the middle child, would defend Dad.
柯蒂斯说他七八岁时就明白了父亲和其他父亲不一样到什么程度。当他抱怨父亲时，中间的孩子罗宾会保护爸爸。
And Robin would get mad at me or Curtis for seeming to be so impatient with Dad. And Curtis and I would sort of look at each other and roll our eyes and think, "Well, you'll know soon enough why we're so impatient." And now Robin is to the age where she's feeling impatient with Jon. And Caroline is very defensive and runs to his defense. And I know that within a couple of years, she'll be more aware of it.
罗宾会因为我或柯蒂斯对爸爸似乎那么没耐心而对我们生气。柯蒂斯和我会互看一眼，翻个白眼，心想：“好吧，你很快就会知道我们为什么这么没耐心了。”现在罗宾长大了，她也开始对乔恩感到不耐烦了。而卡罗琳很护短，跑去维护他。我知道过几年，她也会意识到这一点。
At this point, Kim says, the six-year-old is just realizing that dad isn't "Wonder Dad." She gets mad when he scribbles a phone number on her drawings, or when he invited a TV crew to come and film in their house on her birthday. He just is not aware of other people's feelings in any normal sort of way.
此时，金说，6岁的孩子只是开始意识到爸爸不是“万能爸爸”。她会因为他在她的画上乱涂电话号码而生气，或者在他邀请电视组来家里拍她的生日时感到不快。他只是在某种正常层面上对别人的感受缺乏认知。
When he does play with the kids, or draw with them, or just goof around with them, it's easy for him to go too far, get too loud.
当他确实和孩子们玩，或者和他们画画，或者只是逗他们玩时，他很容易走得太远，变得太吵闹。
Sometimes he comes out when kids are in the middle of a game and he starts making up rules for them to follow when they're in the middle of their game. Like he says, "Here's the rule. You have to go down the skateboard sitting down and you can't get up until you're to the bottom of the hill." And he just makes up rules and it doesn't even occur to him that the kids don't want him to be doing the rules. He just thinks he's having fun and stuff. And then he asks for a turn on the skateboard.
有时他在孩子们玩游戏玩到一半时出来，在游戏中间开始为他们编造必须遵守的规则。他说：“规则是这样的。你必须坐着滑下滑板，直到到达山底前不准起身。”他只是编造规则，他甚至没想到孩子们并不想让他制定规则。他只是觉得他在享受乐趣之类的。然后他还要求滑板让他玩一轮。
It doesn't occur to him that it's kids being with kids and that they don't really want an adult around.
他没想到这是孩子和孩子之间的游戏，他们并不想身边有个大人。
He is a kid.
他就是个孩子。
He is one of the kids. Does he embarrass you?
他就是孩子中的一员。他让你尴尬吗？
Yeah, in lots of different ways.
是的，以很多种方式。
What makes it all so tricky is that Jon Sarkin has better days and worse days. It is possible for him to focus and act more normal and be a bit more clear-headed. But he says this gets exhausting after half an hour, and sometimes, even when he tries to do the right thing, he guesses wrong.
让这一切如此棘手的是，乔恩·萨金有状态好和状态坏的日子。他有可能集中注意力表现得更正常，头脑更清醒一点。但他表示这半小时后就会精疲力竭，有时，即使他试图做正确的事，他也猜错了。
I should point out here that when Jon had his stroke, Kim and he had only been married for two years. Curtis was just a baby. Robin and Caroline hadn't been born. And Kim decided not only to remain with him but to have more children. She did it, she says because at first, the doctors predicted a full recovery. And then, every year, he did get better for a long time. And she loves kids, wanted more kids.
我应该在此指出，当乔恩中风时，金和他结婚才两年。柯蒂斯当时还是个婴儿。罗宾和卡罗琳还没出生。金不仅决定留在他身边，还决定生更多的孩子。她说她这样做是因为起初，医生预测他会完全康复。然后，每年他确实在很长一段时间里都在好转。而且她喜欢孩子，想多要几个。
And so I thought to myself, well, if Jon gets better, it'll be nice for us to have another baby because it's sort of a new hope. And I didn't want the kids spaced too far apart. And I thought if he doesn't get better, it would be easier on Curtis to have a sibling to share that with, I would think. So I thought, we're just going to go for it. And we decided to have Robin and his family was really happy about that because it sort of showed that I was committed and that we were committed and that we were still a family.
所以我心想，好吧，如果乔恩好转，生个新宝宝对我们来说会很好，因为这算是一种新的希望。我不想让孩子们年龄差得太远。我想如果他没好转，有一个兄弟姐妹一起分担这件事对柯蒂斯来说会更容易。所以我心想，我们干脆就生吧。我们决定生下罗宾，他家里人对此非常高兴，因为这算是证明了我很坚定，我们很坚定，我们依然是一个家庭。
When you promise to stay together in sickness and in health, you do wonder, what if something happens, an accident, something disabling? But you don't think, what if your partner just suddenly changes into someone else, someone very irritating? Kim says that she can still confide in Jon, lean on him in certain ways, but there are plenty of ways in which she can't, which he understands.
当你承诺在疾病和健康中相守时，你确实会想，如果发生了什么事，意外，某种残疾，会怎么样？但你不会想，如果你的伴侣突然变了一个人，一个非常令人恼火的人，会怎么样？金说她依然可以向乔恩倾诉，在某些方面依靠他，但在很多方面她做不到，乔恩也明白这一点。
Were the two of you very close before all this happened?
在这之前，你们俩亲密吗？
I would have to say closer than most couples.
我得说比大多数夫妻都要亲密。
And now?
现在呢？
Less close.
没那么亲密了。
And do you think your kids yearn for you to change? Or do they understand that you're not going to change?
你觉得你的孩子们渴望你改变吗？还是他们明白你不会改变？
Both. I still do. I still yearn for it to change, even though I know it's not going to.
两者都有。我依然这样做。我依然渴望它能改变，尽管我知道它不会。
Curtis, is there a part of you where you feel like, well, he should know better?
柯蒂斯，你内心有没有一部分觉得，好吧，他应该更懂事点？
Yeah, I feel that a lot. But I know that he really can't help it and I just try very hard to remember that. And I do feel, sometimes, that he should know better or he should think first, but I know he really can't help it. It's very frustrating.
是的，我有这种感觉。但我知道他真的无能为力，我只是非常努力地记住这一点。有时我确实觉得他应该更懂事或者应该三思而后行，但我知道他真的做不到。这非常令人沮丧。
Do you think he might change sometime?
你觉得他可能会有改变吗？
No, I don't. He's been acting this way for a long time and I don't think he'll change. I have to say, it doesn't seem he's getting any better. It seems like he's getting worse.
不，我不觉得。他这样表现已经很长一段时间了，我不认为他会改变。不得不说，看起来他没在变好。看起来他在变糟。
Does it?
是吗？
Yeah. Like at Caroline's birthday, he just sat around and did nothing. And then he went and took a nap. And he just sat around and did nothing. Didn't even join the party. And then, after we'd already done presents and practically anything, he says to me, "Curtis, what are we doing first, cake or presents?" And we'd already done presents and we were just about to start cake. So it's hard.
是的。就像在卡罗琳生日那天，他只是坐在那儿什么也没做。然后去睡了一觉。他就在那儿坐着，什么也没做。甚至没参加聚会。然后，在我们拆完礼物、几乎做完一切之后，他问我：“柯蒂斯，我们先做什么，蛋糕还是礼物？”我们都已经拆完礼物了，正要切蛋糕。所以这很难。
After the party, when everybody was cleaning up, Jon took the special bouquet of helium birthday balloons and was about to pop them. He thought he was helping. And what happens in the Sarkin family is what happens in any family. It is hard for the rest of them not to think, despite themselves, "Well, doesn't he love us? Doesn't he love us enough to act differently?"
聚会后，当大家都在收拾时，乔恩拿起那束特殊的生日氦气球，正要戳破。他以为他在帮忙。萨金一家发生的事情，也是任何家庭会发生的事情。其余的人真的很难不克制自己去想，“好吧，他不爱我们吗？难道他不爱我们到不愿做出改变吗？”
And that's where we get upset with him is, he should know that the helium balloons are important to me. He should know that that drawing I made is too important to draw on. He should know that stuff. And he says, "No, I don't." And I say, "Well, I think that sometimes you use the stroke a little bit." And it is hard to distinguish when he's using it and when it's really a perceptual problem.
这就是我们对他感到难过的地方，他应该知道氦气球对我来说很重要。他应该知道我画的那幅画很重要，不能在上面画画。他应该知道这些东西。而他说：“不，我不知道。”我说：“好吧，我觉得你有时有点在利用中风。”很难分辨他什么时候在利用它，什么时候真的是感知问题。
My wife is like, "Well, Jon, I think you're lazy because you use the stroke as an excuse. And I can't tell if you're really just being lazy." And sometimes, she's right. Sometimes I am lazy. Sometimes, I actually can't do it. Just like I can't remember where the light switch is, even though I've turned the lights on a thousand times. And I tell her, "I really can't." And she says, "Yes you can." "No, I can't." "Yes, you can." "No, I can't." And I'm like, "Well, guess what. I'm not going to do it because I know I can't, so end of conversation."
我妻子说：“好吧，乔恩，我觉得你很懒，因为你把中风当作借口。我看不出你是不是真的只是懒。”有时，她是对的。有时我确实很懒。有时，我真的做不到。就像我记不住电灯开关在哪，尽管我已经开过一千次灯了。我告诉她：“我真的做不到。”她说：“是的，你能。”“不，我不能。”“是的，你能。”“不，我不能。”我心想：“好吧，你猜怎么着。我不会去做的，因为我知道我做不到，所以谈话结束。”
"I want him to care more. I would think that no matter how bad your situation is, you've got these three marvelous children and a nice wife and a nice home. And things aren't that bad for us. And I know that life is really hard for Jon, but I would like it if we were more of an inspiration for him, to him. That part, I can't let go of hoping will change.
“我希望他在乎更多。我认为无论你的处境有多糟，你拥有这三个出色的孩子、一个好妻子和一个舒适的家。情况对我们来说并没有那么糟糕。我知道生活对乔恩来说确实很难，但我希望我们能对他更有感召力。这一部分，我无法放弃希望，希望它能改变。”
And so this is where they stand. During my brief visit with the Sarkins, Jon was, everybody says, on his best behavior. If anything, he tiptoed around, worried that he'd mess things up as everybody set the table or cleaned the kitchen. When Curtis's little sisters needed help fixing the TV, it was Curtis they came to, not their dad.
这就是他们的立场。在我短暂拜访萨金家期间，大家都说，乔恩表现得最好。如果说有什么不同的话，他小心翼翼，担心在大家摆桌子或打扫厨房时把事情搞砸。当柯蒂斯的小妹妹们需要帮助修电视时，她们找的是柯蒂斯，而不是爸爸。
Interestingly, Kim says that some of the nicest times for her are when they visit with his family-- his mom, his brother, his sister. Family roles are so powerful, something kicks in with Jon.
有趣的是，金说，对她来说最美好的时光是当他们拜访他家人时——他妈妈、他哥哥、他姐姐。家庭角色太强大了，乔恩身上会启动某种东西。
I love just sitting around and listening to him talking to his brother and his sister because the old Jon seems to come back. But he's also exhausted after those trips because-- and it's not like he's deceiving them or anything. He longs to be the old Jon too, but he can only be for so long.
我喜欢就坐在那里，听他和他哥哥姐姐说话，因为以前的乔恩好像回来了。但在那些旅行结束后，他也很疲惫——而且并不是他在欺骗他们之类的。他渴望成为以前的乔恩，但他只能持续那么久。
When we called the Sarkins this week, we found out that the family is still together. He's still married. The girls are teenagers. Curtis is a freshman in college. And Jon continues to create art.
本周我们致电萨金家时，发现他们一家依然在一起。他依然保持婚姻。女孩们已经是青少年了。柯蒂斯是大一新生。乔恩继续创作艺术。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton and Blue Chevigny. Contributing editors for this show, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help comes from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef. [ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和布鲁·谢维尼参与。本节目的特约编辑有保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、马吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作助理有塞斯·林德和艾米丽·优素福。[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can get our free, weekly podcast, or you can listen to any of our shows for absolutely free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获取我们免费的周更播客，或者免费收听我们的任何节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. Whenever I go up to him to talk about the budget or advertising or marketing for the radio show, he responds by saying,
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监管由托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生负责。每当我去找他谈预算、广告或广播节目的营销时，他都会回答说：
I don't know. I have to go look it up in The Lesbian Love Handbook of Life.
我不知道。我得去《女同性恋爱情生活手册》里查查。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。